Game of Thrones Season 6 episode 2 is
out and so much huge stuff happens let's
get right into it we begin beyond the
wall with bran and Bloodraven known in
the books as a three-eyed crow and in a
show as a three-eyed Raven
remember blood Raven is a sort of a
mystical mysterious tree wizard dude
connected to the old gods and the
children of the forest he trains bran to
use the powers of a green seer which
involves walking into animals and having
visions of the present and past this
scene is one of those visions it's of
Winterfell years ago with a young Ned
Stark Benjen stark Lyanna stark Rodrik
Cassel old nan and Hodor more crude we
say Willis who talks
Hodor talks which raises the question of
what happened book readers have been
theorizing for years that Hodor might
have had his mind broken by seeing
something cold and terrible in the
Winterfell crypts or maybe that during
one of brands visions he might mess with
jung-ho doors mind by trying to talk to
him or warg into him from the present
either way it's really cool that they're
bringing us up in the show
maybe we'll finally find out why Hodor
Hodor it's also awesome to see the young
stock siblings especially lianna she's
the one who gets caught up with Prince
Rhaegar Targaryen which leads to
Robert's rebellion the death of Liana
and the theories claimed the birth of
Jon Snow which will probably finally be
revealed next episode check out the R +
L equals J video if you want to know
more so yet heaps happening up here but
mirror is pretty down to be fair her
brother died she's stuck in a cave in a
frozen wasteland and all she's got for
company is Hodor a creepy elf child
owned a couple of [ __ ] tree wizards
getting high on green dreams it is
interesting that this child of the
forest says that brand lot of folks
thought he would that had slowly become
one with a tree like Bloodraven because
really where's he going to go he still
can't walk outside of the matrix of his
visions is Hodor going to carry him all
the way south in winter to the wall is
that where bran will fight the war for
the dawn against the White Walkers
whatever that means exactly and can
bloodraven really be trusted
the plots progressing quickly so we'll
probably find out soon at the wall
Allison and his men confront Davos and
the loyal black brothers but one one
bursts in with the wildlings and Tom
an eID who take Castle black from the
watch props to this guy for thinking he
could kill a 14-foot giant with the
crossbow bolt but luck next time but
yeah like Elsa says it really is an
historic thing to see wildlings in
control at Castle black in the thousands
of years of the watch this has as far as
we know never happened before then down
in King's Landing some common block is
talking smack about Cersei so Robert
strong turns up and splatters his brain
on the wall the mountain has always been
scary because he's so huge and violent
but now that he's an unspeaking
unfeeling undead monster the mountain is
more terrifying than ever
but anyway King Tommen bars Cersei from
going to masalas funeral at the Sept we
learned Tommen did this to try to
protect her he feels guilty feels like
he failed her so later he goes and asks
for forgiveness and asks for Cersei to
teach him how to be strong which can't
possibly go well you can almost see some
Joffrey and Tommen dies sometimes back
at the SERPs Jaime threatens the high
Sparrow and the sparrow threatens right
back saying together we can come over
throw an empire which sounds like a very
political goal for these religious
fanatics to have right do they really
just want to punish sinners for their
sins or do they want to establish a
whole new order in the capital there are
conspiracy theories about the high
Sparrow trying to explain who he is and
what he wants but honestly none of it's
all that convincing hopefully we'll find
out more about the sparrows in the
episodes to come over in Mereen Tyrion
Varys missandei and grey worm have a
strategic chat Varys says that the
slavers have taken back young Chi and a
stupor which could lead to a siege of
murine like in the books then Tyrion
visits the Dragons down in the basement
and he doesn't get roasted like one
character does in the books in fact
Tyrion and the Dragons seem to get along
Tyrion has this touching moment talking
about his childhood dreams of dragons
like a kid talking about dinosaurs and
the dragons seem to listen and
understand which reminds us how little
we know about the Dragons how
intelligent are they how loyal are they
and just how destructive can they be now
that Tyrion has Unchained of them will
probably soon see also this connection
Tyrion seems to have with the Dragons
might support the theory that Tyrion is
not the son of Tywin Lannister but of
the Mad King Aerys Targaryen this is a
controversial thing
but it could almost make sense having
Targaryen blood may allow Tyrion to one
day ride a dragon like Daenerys does and
Tyrion does have experience designing
unconventional saddles so who knows then
were in Braavos with IO and the wave
beats are up again asking her what her
name is
because the faceless men want to let go
of her identity and become no one the
waif leaves and jack and Hagar appears
or more likely the waif wearing jackets
face remember last season someone who
seemed to be Jack and drank poison and
died then the way for Jack ins face
showing that any faceless man can be
Jack and because the faceless men are no
one and have no personal identity but
anyway I was told that a time as a
beggar is done and she has to take on a
new identity
probably mercy the girl who works in a
theater troupe at Winterfell
Walder gives birth to a son since Ramsay
is a bastard this baby boy is ahead of
Ramsay in the line of succession
so Ramsay stabs his father and murders
his stepmother and his newborn baby
half-brother with dogs as though Ramsay
could possibly be hated any more than he
already is it is a little surprising
that Roose goes down so easily because
in the books at least rusa is pretty
good at manipulating and controlling his
monstrous bastard but here he seems to
get totally caught off guard
regardless Ramsay's in charge at
Winterfell now we see he has a support
of the Karstarks and also mentions the
manderlys and the umbers the umbers are
based at last hath and that's where oh
she takes Rick on all those seasons ago
you and OSHA and shaggy-dog head for the
last hearth
so maybe the umbers will give the
Bolton's Rickon as a hostage we also
hear round his plan to attack Castle
black to catch Sansa and kill Jon he
thinks it's going to be easy but what he
doesn't know is that wildlings and a
giant now God Castle black somewhere
near Winterfell Sansa Theon Brienne and
pod chill in the snow Brienne tell Sansa
about when she saw Arya which is the
first senses heard of her sister since
like season 1 Brienne doesn't mention
that I was with the Hound which would be
interesting for Sansa since she's
tangled with Sandor before
Sansa says she should have gone with
Brienne when she had the chance last
season which she really really should
have and then Santa talks with Theon
about the guilt he feels for his crimes
he's still very much
a broken man here while Bryant X answer
to the wall Theon decides to head home
to the Iron Islands at the Iron Islands
we finally see ours father bail on
Greyjoy the winner of the war of the
five kings basically because everyone
else forgot about him like Yara says
Balin should really quit while he's
ahead but the fool seems set on invading
the north again then Balin bumps into
his long-lost brother euron greyjoy
the crows eye a notorious pirate schemer
and madman who declares he wants to rule
and throws Balin off a bridge to his
death below in the books this may have
gone differently
it's hinted that you Ron may have hired
a faceless man like jacket or the wife
to kill Balaam which is connected to all
sorts of other crazy theories about
dragon eggs and Valyria we'll talk about
this in an upcoming video but anyway
King Balin is finally dead which means
the Iron Islands needs a new king Yara
is baylin's chosen heir which could make
her the first ever female ruler of the
Ironborn but Yara's other uncle Aron
tells her they're going to hold a
Kingsmoot a sort of an election to
choose the next king Euron will be a
candidate he's the crazy big talking
outsider while Yara is a relatively
sensible candidate who hopes to be the
first to have a woman in power and in
the books there are also other
candidates including one with a truly
inspiring but possibly unrealistic
utopic vision
anyway back at the wall Melisandre is
still a wreck she's lost her faith and
is deeply depressed she's wearing furs
to keep herself warm which is a big deal
because previously the cold never
bothered her her faith and her inner
fire kept her warm the Lord's fire lives
so she's really in a bad place but Davos
comes in and gives her a pep talk and
Mel agrees to try to resurrect John he
look sexier as a corpse than most men do
living readers have been waiting for
this moment for almost five years and
they've often imagined the resurrection
as something big and dramatic and
magical involving blood sacrifice or a
burning pyre or weirwoods or White
Walkers so it's surprising that all it
took in the end was a sponge bath and a
haircut it will most certainly be very
different in the books but this way kind
of makes sense too it's very similar to
how Thoris of mere first resurrects
beric Dondarrion Thoris didn't have much
faith but he says some prayers anyway
and barek rises from the dead but the
thing about beric is that when he's
resurrected he loses parts of himself
bits of Ease identity
and memories George Martin the author of
the book says that when his characters
are resurrected they're worse for wear
in some ways not even the same
characters anymore they've changed or
transformed and they've lost something
it's also implied that this gets worse
the longer the body's left dead before
resurrection so at least in the books we
should expect John to be a changed man
but the show might want to keep things
simple and make John the same snow we
know and love either way John snow is
back this could be a fulfillment of the
prophecy of azor Ahai he could be the
champion of Lord of Light prophesied to
fight against the walkers on the whites
his freed from his watch vows now so if
L plus L equals J is true he could be
crowned as the rightful king and at the
very least we can expect John to ride
south against the Bolton's perhaps to
embrace his identity not just as a
watchman or a snow but as a stark so
we're just two episodes into season six
and so much huge stuff has already
happened
brands getting visions of the past
wildlings have taken the wall Jamie and
sparrows are clashing and Robert strong
is on the loose the dragons are free and
marine ire is taking on a new role in
Braavos Ramsay takes control at
Winterfell Brienne and Sansa head north
while Theon heads home to the Iron
Islands Lake Huron arrives in the stage
is set for an election and at Castle
black
John is back and the setup is in place
for his true parentage to be revealed
we're really starting to pass the books
now which means anything could happen if
you want to know about John's true
parentage check out the UH plus l equals
J video if you want to know about the
Tyrion Targaryen Theory check that video
out and if you want to hear the word
Hodor for two and a half minutes
watch the Hodor video special thanks to
the channel roar rest' for supporting
this video
roars two covers Game of Thrones and A
Song of Ice and Fire as well as comics
sci-fi and other pop culture so click
the link in the description if you'd
like to check her out many thanks also
to all patrons supporting the channel
including Eli kyani Stacey McGuirk earth
Gary Davis Jeffrey James Edmond Dantes
Jake toner Jessica Rhema quarter angel
Figueroa and Nile monalee Michael Cantu
Mike Bruno Sean Powell Jessica O'Keefe
Randolph and Randall Huggins thanks for
watching please like and subscribe see
you next week